nous avons vu savoir pour quelles
raisons d'abord un éditeur accepte de
publier de tels documents est pourquoi
en quelque sorte qu'il se fait complice
de deux telle heure écrite en prison et
est publié ouais maintenir
l'administration pénitentiaire moniteurs
qui se respecte qui compte avant tout
c'est pas la qualité de l'auteur sa
qualité du manuscrit
c'est pas qu'ils disent est ce que l'on
dit en fait vous vous donnez de la
promotion un personnage assez assez
sordide et finalement vous ne déprécier
pas un petit peu le métier d'éditeur
l'audition de cette façon et je m'étais
dit vous avez un jugement moral sur un
autre livre sur un livre il avait un
jugement moral sur un homme le l'éditeur
est là pour témoigner
lorsque l'on parle du goulag lorsqu'on
parle vague d'offres hitler l'éditeur
est là pour témoigner
il n'a pas à juger c'est pas parce qu'on
publie un livre sur le goulag quand et
pour le goulag c'est pas parce que je
publie l'histoire de jacques mesrine que
j'approuve jacques mais vous ne pouvez
pas que c'est un peu choquant de voir un
avocat devenir un peu l'imprésario
littéraire de son client je ne suis pas
l'impression rideau littéraire de mon
client je n'ai connu une manuscrit que
lorsque l'éditeur a bien voulu me le
communiqué
je ne suis pas non plus un censeur comme
l'éditeur lui même nous n'avons pas à
l'être et jacques merina une
personnalité telle qu'on ne lui dicte
pas la conduite à tenir
vous ne trouvez pas que les que les
prisons devienne un petit peu trop je
crois des salons littéraires aujourd'hui
on a un papillon a bien marché alors
pourquoi pas continuer mais il est
intéressant monsieur que les prisons
deviennent des salons littéraires
c'est mieux que de devenir des
antichambres des actions meurtrières et
criminel on a beaucoup plus de chance
nous avocats de voir un individu se
réhabiliter lorsqu'il a écrit des livres
et pourquoi l'on lorsqu'il en aura
touché les droits alors que sortent en
prison il n'a rien est bien certain que
cela les aidera et je favoriserai de
toutes mes forces
cette possibilité pour les détenus de
s'exprimer
[Musique]